the cold wet weather is the perfect
stage for yada Mohammed's project
Olive residue discarded in the process
of making olive oil is being turned into
something useful the idea started
because of the continuous electricity
and energy crisis here in Gaza
especially when it comes to homes and
chicken farms this motivated us this
project is part of 31 innovative ideas
funded by the International Committee of
the Red Cross and Red Crescent these
blocks burn easily and are now being
used to heat chicken farms here in the
Gaza Strip this saves the bomb is 60% on
heating costs to keep their chickens
warm it's also secure as he doesn't have
to fear shortages of electricity which
is controlled by Israel a lot of forms
lost their birds due to the power cuts
in the winter now this is the final
product and it's basically compressed
olive pomace and they don't add anything
else to it now it's highly flammable and
it's a simple idea but one that provides
a much needed source of alternative
energy here and of course a boost to the
income of the producers they tell us
they now make around $14 each a day
selling to the private sector and they
have plans to expand their business
there are similar ambitions here at sada
almos DeLuise house she's a biologist
and is making stevia sweetener derived
from plants native to South America
it's an idea she started looking into a
few years ago as her family has a
history of diabetes and she wanted to
help London live to father the mother
supercoppa huzzah how earlier in Gaza
the fourth cause of death is diabetes
around 60,000 people are diabetic also
around 78% suffer from obesity so the
idea is to create a safe alternative for
sugar and other industrial sweeteners
she says this green house is just the
beginning and wants to come up with more
nature-based solutions
Gaza people they don't need a
humanitarian assistance they just need
an opportunity people came with
innovative ideas
NEADS from from their from their
environment and this is the accountable
humanitarian action that can can be seen
in an areas like Gaza like the places
where armed conflict impacting the lots
of people over half of Gaza's population
is unemployed and when it comes to
University educated adults the jobless
rate is over 70 percent Israel in
Egypt's blockade of Gaza isn't just
physical it has an enormous impact on
mental health too this project
highlights just a few of Gaza's
innovative minds there are so many
others here in simple need of an
opportunity to show what they're capable
of Stephanie Decker al Jazeera in the
southern Gaza Strip